breaking news meanwhile coming out of
South Wales a major incident has been
declared after a suspected gas explosion
in Morriston specifically at the
junction of field close and clydach Road
in Morriston and it's not known at this
time if there are any injuries or
fatalities further updates to follow and
people are being asked to avoid the area
whilst it is being investigated South
police South Wales police Swansea have
tweeted
avoid the area and then their tweet goes
on to say emergency services are
responding to an incident on the
junction of field close and clydett Road
in Morristown Morriston please avoid the
area whilst we deal with the incidents
so we'll bring you more on that to
potential gas explosion when we have it